It's, it's not easy to be great.
It's very challenging that commitment, that consistency over time.
And that's one of the things Colby studies just like it's simple math.
I just put in double the hours as everyone else. When I was a teenager,
it was the first year he started playing basketball at a summer camp.
He didn't score one point in this whole, like summer, uh,
and this tournament that he played in and then he started doing double the hours
and the next year he was like the highest score. He was like,
it was simple math. I wasn't more talented. I simply put in more.
[Inaudible].
Pretty solid segue for about 30 reasons to get to a little bit of your,
your chat with Kobe Bryant,
because I think it encapsule encapsulates so much of what you're talking about.
So I watched it again this morning and we talked about it when I was on your
show. And I hadn't seen the interview of you and Coby.
And what I said to you in that interview was that this was just a few weeks
after, after he died,
is that it felt like it was like a rip in the universe because it's hard to
fathom putting aside the tragedy of all the other people in his daughter,
of course, but those aren't public people that we know, but of course it's as,
as equal a tragedy, obviously,
but there was something about Coby that it was like,
I told you I was watching sports, uh, you know, the,
the spectrum Lakers channel the day before.
And I saw him and he was just being interviewed and he's in a suit and he's got
the beard and he looks really sharp. And I was like, man,
that guy's just living his best life. That was literally the day before.
And it feels like a rip in the universe when someone who's doing all of the
things that you just described, who has reached the pinnacle of their sport,
but then flourished after and started this basketball Academy and a good
jillion, other things then disappears from the earth.
So can you just talk a little bit about what it was like to sit down with Colby
and what it taught you and did he have all of those pieces?
Cause, cause literally just everything that you just laid out right there,
that's what he was talking about in the interview.
And you could see it was real there, there was no BS behind.
Yeah. It was a powerful experience. The whole,
the whole setup of it was powerful. We booked the interview the day before.
So I didn't really have much time to prep,
which was probably a good thing for me.
Cause I didn't have like two weeks to think about it. I've got Colby.
It was like literally booked it at 6:00 PM. I think the night before.
And then I was there at 6:00 AM the next morning and his office in the OSI.
And I remember, uh, the most powerful thing he taught me was not what he said,
but his example and what I mean by that is when we got to his office,
I think it was probably around six, 15, six 30.
The interview was at eight o'clock and I knew I was, the publicist was like,
you've got 20 minutes. I think she originally said, you've got 15 minutes,
but I was like, please give me 20. Right when I asked two questions. Yeah,
we get there.
And the assistant opens the door for us and there's a big office space in the
orange County. And she says where we normally film. But my mind,
I was like that doesn't really look that good.
Can I look around the office and see if there's another spot we can set up our
cameras.
So we walked through the office and we go down kind of this long hall with,
um, conference rooms on each side of the hallway with glass windows,
you can see inside the conference rooms.
And then it walks down into another big open space of more
office, uh, chairs and things like that. Walked down.
I see the other room. I'm like, I don't really like anything here.
Let's go back to the original space.
So we walked back through the glass hallway and the last window on
the left, I see it. The lights are off and the back of the room, probably 20,
30 feet back.
I see a shadow of a man like this looking up open
ceiling and no computer scheme was on.
There was no phone in his hand look real quick.
Double-take and I see it's Coby sitting there like this, just looking at it.
This is six 15 in the morning. And I'm thinking our interview is not till eight.
And I'm thinking to myself, I asked the assistant, I go, what's that Toby?
She goes, yeah. And I go, what's he doing here so early?
Like this is his company. This is his space. Why's he here she goes,
he's been here for almost an hour. And he was at the gym with his daughter.
The one who passed away at 4:00 AM working out with her and he comes here.
He's always the first one here. And he's always the most prepared.
Just that moment alone of seeing Kobe as a shadow, looking up.
And I can only imagine he was visualizing his dream. He was going over, uh,
you know, his game film for the day.
He was planning what he was going to be talking about.
There was an interview with me afterwards, with little Wayne who was there.
So they were setting up and another part, it was kind of a surreal,
just morning, little Wayne and all his body guards.
And this whole kudu crew was there.
I'm there with one person setting up our three cameras and we're like, Hey,
you know, and I was just like, this is surreal.
And about an hour, about 15 minutes before interview.
So for another hour we're half the lights are off in this room and now people
starting to come in around eight 30 in the, in the office. And so there's some,
there's some activity happening and I'm sitting there in the chair,
just kind of waiting, just trying to like be ready.
I don't know if he's going to come out early. Is he coming out on time?
I don't know what's happening.
He ends up coming out probably two minutes before eight o'clock the start time.
And the publicist gave me a,
a bunch of papers of everything,
not to ask him a list of things you can not talk about from his past or his
parents to all these things. Like don't mention this, don't mention this.
I mean a list I've never had this before.
And so I know to myself,
I've got two minutes to connect with. Arguably the greatest of all time,
who's just won an Oscar as well, by the way.
And two minutes to connect before our 20 minute interview,
right? What am I going to say? And hopefully he doesn't, you know,
when you meet people that are really famous and you're inspired by then you meet
them and you're like, gosh, I'm really let down by them. They.
Say, never meet your heroes. Right?
And this guy was a complete opposite. He was right away,
came up to me and gave me a big handshake and was just like, Hey,
thank you so much for being here really means a lot to me.
We're trying to get the message out about our podcast.
Like thank you for taking the time. Look me in the eyes.
First thing I said to him was like, I just want to say, thank you.
I work with our I'm friends with a lot of Olympians.
And all of them say that during the last couple of Olympics,
you were the most giving athlete that you would show up to,
to other sporting events that you would take photos with everyone in the,
you know,
in the village and during lunches that you were just so kind and giving.
So as a, as a USA handball player,
I want to thank you for how you show up during this times. And right away,
he goes, you play handball. And I go, yeah, I love handball. And he goes,
I love handball playing it in Italy, growing up.
That's all I did as a F as a fun activity. And I go amazing. Yeah,
it's such a great sport. I wish we had it here, the USA more. And then, um,
I mentioned a couple of people we had in common and he's like, man,
those guys are my brothers. Like, I love that.
I'm glad we have some good connections. And I said, one more thing. I said,
you know, your, your team has told me what not to share and what not talk about,
is there anything else off limits that I shouldn't talk about? And he said,
rip that up, ask me anything you want and take as long as you want.
So I was only supposed to have 20 minutes.
We have to think we went 40 to 45 and I tried to be respectful because the
publicist kept saying, like wrap it up in the background. And I was like, okay,
let me be respectful.
But even the last few questions he answered and we was talking about like his
whole mission was to tell great stories and him talking about love and
family. For me, it was really inspiring. Not only the words he says,
but his example,
he isn't just saying work hard and outwork everyone he's actually showed me as
an example. I didn't know if he was going to,
if he was going to see me seeing him that morning,
like he didn't think I was going to walk past his office cause I wasn't supposed
to. But he was there. Just that example of,
I don't get to my place 30 minutes before my interviews. Right. You,
I guess, I mean, you come in when you're ready,
but it's like just that example of hard work is shows why he was so
great. And that was inspiring to me.
Isn't it interesting that, you know,
they say the same thing about Michael Jordan. He outworked everybody. He,
he practiced the hardest, like you'd think that every athlete would be like, Oh,
that's the obvious way to do it.
Or forget athletes that all of us in our lives would be like, Oh,
you want to be the best at what you do. You got to work the hardest.
You've got to show up first and you got to leave the last and blah, blah, blah.
And yet 99.9, nine, nine, 9% of us. Don't do it.
Even though you look at the guys that you admire most and they're the ones
doing it.
It's a big sacrifice is a lot of time. And a lot of energy in you.
You have to give up so much to go all in on one thing.
So I know why it's hard to do. I mean, it's like he was up at four,
am working out with his daughter and then he at the office at five 30 or
whatever it was or six or whatever it was. And it's like, it's a sacrifice.
We'd much rather be comfortable and sleep more and watch Netflix
more. I like watching Netflix. It's it's not easy to be great.
It's very challenging. The commitment that consistency over time.
And that's one of the things Colby studies just like, it's simple math.
I just put in double the hours as everyone else. When I was a teenager,
it's the first year he started playing basketball at a summer camp.
He didn't score one point in this whole, like summer. Uh,
and this tournament that he played in and then he started doing double the hours
and the next year he was like the highest score. And he was like,
it was simple math. I wasn't more talented. I simply put in more hours.
It's a good transition to something else that he said that I think is
interesting where he talked,
you were asking him about when he was sort of hitting his stride.
And he talks about this moment where Shaq is injured for like eight games that
he scored, I think 40, over 40 and eight straight games or something like that.
And then Phil Jackson calls him into the office when Shaq comes back and
basically is like,
now you got to tone it down because now Shaq is back and the East plays
different. So when we get to the finals, we're going to do this differently.
And he, you know, you'd think that he would just be like, no, we're,
we're winning like crazy. I'm better than shackle. We don't even need shack.
You know, they had their own problems later, but, but he basically was like,
yeah. So I listened to the, to the mentor. That's what I wanted to get to.
Cause you talk a lot about mentorship. He listened to the mentor in this case,
Phil Jackson, who had already done this with Jordan and he dialed it back.
And then of course they ended up winning a championship.
If you'd like to be inspired, motivated,
and educated by some of the most successful people around the world,
check out the school of greatness, full episode playlist right over here.
And if you'd like to see Lewis Howes this interview with me,
click right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.